dion waiters
waiters step back and waiters
those guys can make plays in the half
court as well
first quarter winds down dion waiters
say hello to los angeles lakers
and their fans waiters with another
three
waiters only played in three games this
year for miami
and waders hits the 17-footer 69-61
two-point lead dion waiters welcome to
the lakers
he has nine points quinn cook
in the game with j.r smith thd dwight
and devonte
k-cock and right there jr
seized white howard for the alley-oop
great recognition and the role in the
setup by dwight it's great to see these
guys at the big club
jr and one
612 days since his last
nba game making it to the western
conference finals no one's even talking
about him right now they got zach
collins and nurkic back
they got a guy named gametime around the
back
jr as we take a look at jr's play
oh he plays defense too ali james and
brez a little behind the back
from bob on lakers are down five with 28
seconds jr's gonna shoot a three
and he makes it and the lakers are down
just two
[Applause]
bob on just to go ahead and shoot it
we're good